>>Male Announcer: Hello Everyone.
Thank you so much for coming.
This talk is part of the Authors @ Google
Series.
We have a couple of other talks going on this
week, they are both actually tomorrow.
Um, we have Gail Soalid talking about communication
and positive limit setting with young children.
And we have a conversation with Nolan Bushnell
tomorrow.
You can learn more about these at go/@google.
But today we have Patricia Curtan and we are
proud to present her.
Patricia is an artist, designer and print
maker.
She has a long association with Chez Panisse
Restaurant in Berkeley as a cook, a cookbook
co-author, designer and illustrator.
She has designed and printed letter press
and linoleum blocks, special occasion menus
for Chez Panisse for several decades.
The menus have been collected into her recently
published book Menus for Chez Panisse, which
will be on sale in the back for fifteen dollars.
In addition to cookbooks and specialty printing
Patricia has designed images and typography
for logo identity, wine labels, product packaging,
calendars, note cards, book covers and tattoos.
Please join me in welcoming Patricia Curtan.
>> Patricia: Hello, Thank you for inviting
me.
It's really exciting to be at Google.
I came to talk to you about my book and before
I get into exactly showing you all these things
I want to tell you a little bit about my background
and relationship to Chez Panisse, how this
came about.
I actually started working at Chez Panisse
the first year it was opened in 1971, which
was forty years ago.
The restaurant just celebrated it's 40th Anniversary.
And at the time I was an intern at the print
shop of poster artist Davis Lance Goines in
Berkeley and that's how I come to know the
people, Alice, and the people at Chez Panisse
and ended up working there in the dining room.
And so for a time I worked at the day time
at the print shop and in the evenings at the
restaurant.
And then I got very sort of swept up, and
very interested in all that was going on at
the restaurant.
The incredible food and the energy there,
what was going on and I sort of started spending
less time at the print shop and morning then
in the pastry kitchen and then in the other
kitchens and eventually ended up spending
up most of my time in the kitchen and cooking.
Which was a great, wonderful, adventure.
And after a time I ended up then starting
a family and wanted to change that and so
I stopped cooking.
And about that time Alice started getting
contracts to doing cookbooks and we worked
on the first drawing.
And then I just sort of flipped over from
cooking and went back to printing and design
and cookbooks but still working with Chez
Panisse and still working with Alice.
The, it's all still about the same thing which
is really about the beauty of food and but
now I work mostly in two dimensions.
In printing and designing and in making images.
So this book, um, here's the dining room at
Chez Panisse about 5:30 before dinner begins.
It’s a little small place, its very intimate
and these menus that are collected here were
made for primarily the downstairs dining room.
For special occasions such as birthdays, I'm
going to come back to these images, but birthdays,
anniversaries; there is an annual Bastille
Day dinner; there's New Year's Eve celebrations.
And the book is organized chronologically,
so the menus start actually in 1972 and alongside
the menus are short text that tell sort of
different stories about maybe the events or
the person it was made for or some visiting
luminary or some other occasion.
And, uh, before we get into me really showing
you those menus I want to tell you a little
bit about the process of how they are made.
There are letter press menus and I have a
beautiful old cast iron letter press that
is called the Chandler and Price, C and P,
and it is a, it has a clam shell action that
sort of opens and closes like this.
And the paper is fed into the press by hand,
it sits on the area called the platen, it's
a flat area of metal and that's the part that
closes and meets with the block or the type
or whatever is being printed.
You can see the block there vertically.
It's a one color press, prints one color of
ink at a time.
That's the ink plate and the rollers are spreading
the ink on the ink plate and the ink plate
slowly turns with each cycle of the press
and will distribute that ink evenly.
Then it comes down and rolls over the surface
of the block and the press closes and prints
and paper comes out and new paper comes in.
And [clears throat] it was built, and this
press is about one hundred and twenty years
old, still as solid as the day it was made.
It was mainly built to print type, metal type,
hand-set and this is a sample of a little
bit of type setting.
Um, and that's a process that is pretty much
outdated now, purists still do it but it's
putting the type together letter by letter,
space by space, space between the lines, very,
very laborious and handmade.
But recently, the last twenty years or so,
the advent of polymer plate technology has
really regenerated and revitalized letter
press printing.
And that is still the same principle of relief
printing, printing from a raised service-like
type.
But this material is a thin layer of metal
and on that is another layer of polymer material
that has a photo ground coating on the top,
and to make the plate digital type setting
or some other form of image that can be output
as a negative.
The negative and the polymer plate are sandwiched
together, it's exposed to light and where
the light hits the photo ground on the polymer
surface it hardens.
And then the polymer plate is washed in warm
water, it's a great thing because there is
no toxic photo chemicals, it's a pretty benign
process.
And then the softer polymer material just
rinses away and you are left with that relief
surface, so it's a very wonderful, easy technology
that means you don't have to set type and
put the type all back in the box.
So it then locks up in the press, it sits
on a magnetic base so that thin layer of metal
on the back sits on a magnetic base and then
those two things together, the base and the
plate equal a measurement that is type high,
which is the universal height of type, metal
type.
And so that means anything you can make a
plate out of you can lock that up in the press
and print from it.
So a lot of small letter press shops have
come up because you don't have to have all
the equipment and all the type and all of
that, you just need a press and access to
a plate maker and it's done something pretty
wonderful.
But how I make images primarily is linoleum
block and similar to the polymer material,
linoleum block is a thin layer of linoleum
mounted on wood and it's approximate type
high.
I usually have to build up the back of it.
And linoleum is a natural material, this kind
is called battleship linoleum.
It's created out of powered cork and linseed
oil, it was developed by the military just
before World War II to use as flooring for
their battleships and submarines.
And which, you know, it's impervious to water
and it's soft enough to stand on so your legs
don't get tired and it has a sort of a little
porous surface.
It's not flat like metal or polymer and so
when it's printed it has a sort of stippled
texture that I find really beautiful and you
can really identify linoleum from that look
once you know what it is.
And the process of making them, the prints,
the blocks themselves, is I start with a drawing
and then, a pretty simple drawing like this
as you can see.
And then you have to, I use drafting paper,
turn it over and trace it on the back because
when you are working in printing you have
to work in reverse.
And then I put a sort of graphite crayon on
the back and taped that onto the block and
then trace through the drawing onto the block
and that leaves something that looks like
a pencil line on the block.
And I do that for, one block for each color
in the print, cause press prints one color
at a time.
And so if the image has four colors then there
are four blocks and then once that drawing
has been transferred to the linoleum then
it's cut and carved and that's a process of
removing all the negative space in the print.
So as you can see with this leaf the block
on the bottom, you can see the lines of the
gouges where the linoleum has been removed
so that only that part that I want to print
is there.
Here's an example of this violet image, the
image is made from four blocks and the first
one on the left is the dark green leaves of
the image so that was printed first.
And then the second block is of the area under
the leaves, just the solid, and that's a lighter
green so that's coming through the lines that
are cut in the first image, the veins and
inside the stalks there.
The third one is another line image of these,
sort of outlines and interior lines of the
violets and then the last one is the tint,
the purple tint color of the violets.
So those are printed one at a time.
There is also a little bit of an orange that
you will see in the image that is the center
of the flowers that I just added by water
color, it's a little hard to cut those tiny
little spaces and get them in the right place.
So that's the basic process , here's the finished
menu that that was made for, a New Years Eve
menu.
So usually when I am making these menus that
have text I will print the image first and
the last thing that happens is the type is
added at the end, a separate run.
So, as I say, the organization of the book
is the menus are chronological and the first
ones that I made early on were really typographical.
I didn't know how to do this linoleum work
at that time, so I was setting this by hand,
and metal type and using little type ornaments
and that sort of thing.
And another aspect that is sort of fun about
this book is reading what's actually on the
menus.
There, it's kind of a snapshot of the history
of Chez Panisse as well and really what was
being served when and in this case for how
much.
It's pretty astonishing, homemade pastries
for seventy five cents.
Lindsay Shere , who was the pastry chef, the
starting pastry chef at the restaurant, made
fantastic, fantastic desserts and you could
just go in and get wonderful little cappuccino
or a cup of coffee and a slice of her almond
tart and pay one dollar which is pretty amazing.
When the restaurant first opened with their
four course meal, and they just became famous,
I don't know if you know about Chez Panisse
but they became famous for serving one prix
fixe dinner menu a night.
So it was either four or sometimes on weekends
it would be five courses, but when they first
started it was four dollars and fifty cents
for a four course dinner in 1971.
Of course they were losing a lot of money
so [audience laughs] after about six months
I think it went up to six fifty or six twenty
five or something like that.
But now it's far from that.
So I didn't really start making too many menus
until after I stopped cooking.
I would dabble in it a little bit and I did
acquire a press during that time but I didn't
really have time, I was too busy in the kitchen.
But then afterwards when I started working
on the books and I wanted to print more and
I wanted to add images to the type and so
I decided I maybe I would try to do learn
to do this linoleum work.
So this is one of the first blocks I cut,
a single color and it's really pretty simple.
But I was thrilled by it and I thought maybe
I can do this.
And the other way that I was making menus
at the time, was in collaboration with my
husband, Stephen Thomas, who is a print maker
and prints etchings and Intaglio printer.
And so we would collaborate and I would do
a drawing on a copper plate that he would
etch or something else and then combine it
with type and so these are etchings.
And when we were doing these, because it's
a really time consuming process printing etchings,
so it was usually a small number for maybe
that particular party, one table of four or
six or eight or something.
Very small number.
This menu on the left, the menu for the potato
king was for a friend of ours who had an absolute
obsession with potatoes and he always wanted
potatoes with every meal.
It wasn't a meal unless there was some kind
of a potato dish.
So for his birthday we made him a menu that
had potatoes with every course and put together
quickly just this little menu in a couple
of days and Stephen printed it.
The other was for a dinner for James Beard
who didn't often come to the restaurant but
he came this one spring and it was a time
we were just harvesting green garlic, the
young garlic that you only get right in the
spring.
At the time that was a really new thing, now
you see it in all the farmers markets but
that was kind of a big deal to have this young
green garlic so that's what decorated the
menu.
And Stephen and I did a number of New Years
menus together for a few years in a row and
we liked to focus on the celestial theme,
sort of the big picture.
And took some inspiration from some photographs,
NASA photographs that were coming back of
the Earth from space for this one.
Here's another etching, its a mezzotint actually
and this was an astronomical occurrence of
a blue moon, the second full moon within on
calendar month.
And it was that night of the New Years Eve
dinner so we couldn't resist that.
But then I started working on this linoleum
thing and I tried to get better at it doing,
getting a little more ambitious and the images
start out very simple.
These are sort of just shapes with a little
line work in them.
And often the imagery that I would do is,
I was working at the limitations of what I
could manage so they had to be simple.
But sometimes they were inspired by literally
something on the menu that was an ingredient
or something being served.
Or often times it would be something that
represented the season or the time or the
moment.
This one is kind of both.
And here is another sample of the kind of
menu I would do sometimes and often times
if there was somebody special coming in, there
was two days notice that Elizabeth David or
Richard Olney or Julia Child or someone was
coming and Alice really wanted a special menu.
So, in those cases, I would do something very
fast, just set the text in type and print
that and then do hand decorations.
A little drawing and in this case a water
color filling in, for just that small group
of people, that table of four or that table
of six.
This was a special lunch for Richard Olney
again, he is no longer with us but he was
very influential cookbook writer, an American,
an ex-pat who lived in France for most of
his life and wrote about French food and wrote
for an American audience.
He wrote about the Cuisine du Bonne Femmes,
which is just the ordinary wonderfully household
cooking of French homemakers.
And he elevated that and really broke it down
really fantastic books.
So here, this was an important breakthrough
for me, this particular menu because the imagery
is really simple but I drew it from life.
Hadn't been doing that and I got these leaves
and I wanted to somehow get this color and
so I drew the leaves and figured out this
composition and then I had this kind of light
bulb go off and thought well maybe on my press
that has this ink plate that turns around
and spreads the ink, maybe I could disconnect
that.
I disconnected the device that turned the
ink plate and then mixed different colors
and just spread them on the ink plate by hand
and then just let the rollers blend them a
little bit so that if you picture this menu
turned on its side so that the block is ninety
degrees you can see stripes of color; red,
yellow, orange and then more yellow.
And so with one pass through the press, all
these different colors on the ink plate, it
was like, wow this could work.
And it's a little rough, you can see where
those lines aren't there and they are not
blending perfectly, but it was really an exciting
moment and I thought this, this could really
lead to something.
I could play with this.
So then I decided I need to get better at
this drawing thing and I have always been
very influenced by both typographically and
with images and visually by older books.
And I really, really loved old botanics and
herbals.
This is an image from John Gerarde's Herbal
printed in 1633 which was the height of a
scientific text at the time of identifying
plants and what their properties were and,
um, huge, big book.
And these are wood cuts, so single color cut
from wood, same process as linoleum only wood
instead of linoleum.
So I used to pore over these and look at these
and think, try and figure out how to do it.
Maybe I could do something like that or I
would do very simplified versions of them.
And so I started trying to do that sort of
thing of this, like the garlic, bunch of garlic
here.
Which again I was starting to draw from life
because that's what I wanted to see on the
menus.
I couldn't find something directly to sort
of immolate or copy so I was just trying to
use the style but trying to do that.
And like this, you can see the direct influence
of those Herbal wood cuts.
But I wanted also to add color to them so
then I would do the line work in black and
then cut a block and add the screen, to get
a tint.
The purple in that turnip is a little handwork
that was put on with water color.
The other source of imagery that I really,
really loved is Japanese woodblock prints
and that whole tradition.
This print was made by Utamoro in a book called
Song of the Garden that combined his images
with the text of Japanese poets, very popular
book at the time It was printed in 1788.
And I loved the composition of these are so
lyrical and beautiful where, and the combination
of the text with the image and the space in
there.
And I was also looking at like these leaves
which had the line and the color and so graceful
and trying to think how can I sort of incorporate
that in that too.
So I started immolating that and here is an
image made about that time.
This was actually a card that folded in the
middle, so it had a front and a back, but
really conceived of as one image in that Japanese
woodblock style.
[pause] Here's another very simple bu, for
me, kind of markers of the time because I
was breaking these into different colors and
being able to put them together and without
necessarily the black line, but composing
an image of these separate blocks just with
color.
And then using the space like the beautiful
spaces in those Japanese prints.
And this is not anything literal about the
menu, this is flowering quince.
But again it's about the season, about just
a moment, here's where we are right now.
Another homage to Japan with the fade at the
top.
One of the things that has always been very
interesting in the studio and satisfying is
to keep pushing the limits of the medium and
keep pushing the limits of the press itself.
What can I do of this particular machine with
these particular materials?
And how one discovery leads to another and
the emphasis to try something new.
So I had been making some of these special
menus for the downstairs restaurant and Alice
really wanted to have something every night
in there.
Which was very difficult to accomplish, especially
with the changing menu every night, and then
it was always right until the last hour really
that that menu was getting determined.
So I worked out a system where using an 8-1/2
x 11 sheet I could print on one half of it
and then they could set the menu for the evening's
dinner on the computer, output that and then
put these in the copy machine and photocopy
that onto the interior and then fold it and
then there would be this combination of up
to date menu but something pretty and printed.
So I started making these as seasonal imagery
and printed them for about a year and a half
or so, you know like two or three thousand
at a go.
But which was just not sustainable at all
so eventually I designed something that could
be printed offset and they could print multiple
thousands and that would do for awhile.
[pause]
Nowadays they still use that same system and
they reproduce images from illustrations I
made for some of the cookbooks of fruit and
vegetable illustrations.
So about the time, about the time this menu
was made I was working on a book called Chez
Panisse Vegetables where I really, this is
where the sort of drawing really had to get
better.
And my task was to very specifically draw
certain vegetables, fifty different ones and
made prints of these.
And so I really started drawing from life,
going to the garden or brining material into
my studio and I didn't have, that was so consuming
I couldn't really spend too much time making
the menu.
So some of the images I made for that I incorporated
and just said "I can do a menu if it's got
this on it."
But these are images that were made for that
book actually.
But I found that just by doing it more and
doing more and doing it more I did get better
at it.
Here's another example of that split fountain
so-called technique of the multiple colors
in one pass on the ink plate with the leaves
of this image.
These are, these two were for the then First
Lady Hillary Clinton and trying not to be
intimidated by the First Lady I went in just
the absolute opposite way and went very, very
simple.
The one on the left was a lunch and they were
trying to serve as many, gather as many ingredients
as they could from edible school yard in Berkley
to impress upon the First Lady that the beautiful
food that could come from these school garden
projects.
[ pause ] This is a New Year's Eve menu, those
are always celebrated in a some kind of gala
way at the restaurant and extra effort was
put into those menus, the menus for that event
and others, too.
They are really souvenirs and people take
them home and it's a way to remember something
as fleeting as a wonderful dinner, it's quite
a reminder and the experience of being there
at the restaurant.
Here's some more Japanese influence of space
and text and image combination.
These are white dogwoods.
Carrie Glenn was the florist at the restaurant
for decades and she was very, very extraordinary
woman.
She made these amazing floral arrangements
and this was her goodbye party.
Dinner with Mikhail Baryshnikov.
[pause] Here again is that use of that multiple
color technique and this time instead of one
block it's three blocks, so you can--,.
It then becomes more interesting where you
can put them right next to each other.
And you will see in some areas where the leaves
overlap there is a little line, well that
is the double ink of that that instead of
cutting a line, like a drawn line, it's just
where they overprint they make their own line
and it helps to separate one leaf from another,
it's kind of a nice way of subtly doing that.
This was a dinner for his Royal Highness,
the Prince of Wales, who visited the Bay Area
and he's very involved in Brittan in the organic
food movement there, and schools, and school
gardens and organic farming in general in
England, it's pretty great.
So when he came to the United States to visit
he wanted to come to the Bay Area because
there is such a great movement here and he
wanted to visit the Edible School Yard which
they did.
It's very exciting.
And then there was this big dinner for the
both of them.
This is direct influence from Japanese bird
and flower prints.
This was made for the wedding of a very close
friend, he and his partner were married just
before Proposition 8 passed on the ballet
so they were legally married in California.
And the two birds on the branch, they are
red-winged black birds and that, black birds
the only the males have the color on their
wings, the females you know are just all one
color.
So on this branch are two male birds.
And here's another wedding, this one has quite
a bit of detail with rosemary flowers and
this is a combination of printing and then
I went in and I filled in the color and then
the little tiny detail of those flowers by
hand.
So this is really quite enjoyable to do that
kind of handwork actually and you can do things
that are otherwise too subtle to do it on
the press.
Another wedding menu that Chez Panisse did
on a dinner on an island, the wedding was
on the beach.
So I wanted somehow to get sand on the menu
itself and, through some trial and error,
I figured out that if I put some vermiculite
in a little Cuisinart and then broke it up
and then put that on the wet ink when it came
out of the press it would stick to the ink
and then actually made something that looks
very much like sand.
And that is the summary, so thank you I would
be happy to answer any questions if you have
any to talk about that.
[applause]
>> Male #1: What was the main influence of
your choice of that particular press and mechanism?
Was it it's availability or did you seek it
out?
>> Patricia: Well, um, that's actually the
press I first learned to print on when I was
in David Goines' shop.
Someone he, he prints on an offset press but
someone had given him this press and I was
one of a couple of the students of his and
so an older friend of his, a journeyman printer,
came and taught us how to operate this press
and how to print.
And I just fell in love with it.
And I've operated a few other presses but
I really loved that one.
I loved the size of it and the simplicity
of it.
These presses are like vintage cars where
you could open the hood and you could still
how the whole thing works.
It's sort of the opposite of a computer but
it has, it has a very graceful, wonderful
mechanism that kind of fits the body.
It's not a huge big thing but it's good and
solid and very capable and, um, so I, when
I decided I wanted a press I started looking
around and I found one at a used equipment,
printing equipment place and there was that
same press.
I thought, well that's for me.
>> Female #1: Have you ever had any typos?
>> Patricia: [giggles]I can't even count how
many typos.
Yeah.
[laughs] happens all the time.
>> Female #1 : So when you do is it like "Oh
well" or do you have to redo everything?
>> Patricia: If you catch it in time, you
can change it.
But after it's printed it's "Oh well".
But I always try and employ the services of
a friend who is a good proofreader.
You have to have somebody else look at it.
You just, because when you are setting, once
you start printing or once you set it, you
sort of stop seeing it as information, you
see it as shape and where it is on the page.
Proofreaders are a special group of people
to be able to catch that and I am really prone
to typos.
Something I have to watch out for.
>> Female #2: Hi.
For your menus that aren't for special events,
what is the lifetime of the menu?
How many times can you repeat them?
>> Patricia: I'm sorry I didn't hear the question
>> Female #2: What's the lifetime of a menu?
So how many times can you give it to like
a new customer before it gets bad or you know?
>> Patricia: You just use it once, they just
use them once.
>> Female #2: Oh, you just use them once?
Do they get to take it home?
>> Patricia: Yes, absolutely they get to take
them home.
>> Female #2: Oh great, ok.
>> Patricia: So that's what I mean.
The restaurant doesn't advertise, they have
never advertised, they have never done anything
like that and from very early on Alice knew
about good printing, knew about fine printing
and she always loved that.
So that is something she wanted as part of
the restaurant.
So like in the very early days she would get
local printers, and in the Bay Area there
has always been a real printing community
in the Bay Area.
A lot of letter press printers, there still
are.
She would get these printers to make a special
menu or a week of menus or something like
that, very cleverly, in exchange for food
and wine.
[audience laughs] So they were so ready to
do this and then there were always these printers
hanging around late night dinners, a whole
table of printers, drinking and drinking.
So it just became really a part of the signature,
the look and the style and the aesthetic of
the restaurant.
But the ones that they use now they have a,
just kind of an inventory of maybe twenty
images on that 8-1/2 x 11 sheet.
So then they can select for that night what
seems appropriate for that menu or this season
or that time of year.
They print out one for every dinner.
>> Female #2: Sorry, to follow up; what percentage
of people do you think bring home the menus
as opposed to leaving them there?
>> Patricia: Um, I would say on a nightly
basis maybe half.
Of the special menus, you know that hand printed
menus, people catch on to that and they take
them home.
One of the things about letter press, if you
are familiar with it, is it has this very
tactile handmade quality.
You may not know anything about the process
or you may not be familiar with letter press
really, but when you hold it you know something
has happened.
This is, it's handmade and you can tell and
it communicates something.
And it's intimate, it's personal.
That's one of the things I love about the
medium is it's called letter press because
it punches the impression into the paper so
it has a kind of textural, sculptural aspect.
There are shadows where the letter forms are
and it's quite beautiful.
I brought some for you guys to see after its--.
[pause]
>> Male #2 : So on the multi block projects,
how do you keep the registration correct?
>> Patricia: Yeah it is tricky.
I work very, very methodically.
I mean printing is a methodical process, it's
not spontaneous.
You have a plan and you work step by step
and so you have methods of working.
But I start with that drawing you saw and
when I put it on the block and I trace over
the drawing, that part of the drawing for
that part of the image, I'm very faithful
to that line.
So then the line is on the block and then
when I am cutting again I am very faithful
to that line that is the real line, not near
it, not next to it, it's the line.
And then if you get everything sort of on
the blocks in the right place, then you have
the potential for registering it on the press.
Then it's a matter of printing in a likewise
methodical way, but it's just being very careful
at every stage.
And you know, my opinion, there are lots of
ways to go about this.
Many kinds of printing it's not such a tight
registration, it's looser and colors overlap
and it's a little more impressionistic looking.
But my particular style, my particular aesthetic
is for really close registration.
I always kind of go back to early botanicals
and how beautiful they are, those often were
engraved or etched or printed in one color
and hand colored.
A lot of the really ones you might be familiar
with.
But I am trying to do that on the press, I
am trying to kind of figure out a way.
So it's really just working very carefully.
>> Female #3: Do you have a favorite menu
or a favorite story from the menus in your
book?
>> Patricia: Um, it would be hard to pick,
it would be hard to pick one.
The one I showed you with the leaves where
there light bulb went off about the multi-colors,
that one is a favorite for me because it opened
my mind about what I could do on my press.
And I think there is a principle at work there
which is, that partly comes from learning
about cooking at Chez Panisse cause when the
restaurant first started, we really didn't
know what we were doing.
There was a desire to achieve something and
cook fabulous food but most of us were not
trained.
And so Alice would make up these menus and
put dishes on the menus that we had never
cooked before.
And there was one chef who came to work and
stayed for a long time, Jean Pierre Moulle,
he was classically trained and he was French
and he could like bring some hardcore information
and technique into the kitchen.
But we would just put things on the menu and
then try it.
And one thing we figured out right away, and
you, because it's one menu, one night, you
are not duplicating the same thing over and
over again, you are always, there is always
the next night and new things.
But if it didn't work, if we were unsatisfied
with that dish, the thing is you were just
like let's put some version of that one the
menu next week.
And we would do it again, and we would do
it again until we got it and then we had that
technique or we had that dish in the repertoire.
Same thing with something that worked fabulously
well, we would do it again soon so that we
wouldn't forget.
Because when things are changing so often
it is hard to remember, you know you're just
moving all the time.
So that same way of, that same approach I
took into the print studio when I stopped
working in the kitchen, which is go for what
you want to see.
I would try it and sometimes it would work
and sometimes it wasn't but then I would try
it again, try it again.
And eventually you would kind of get there,
so for me some of the memorable menus are
the ones where I really, I really discovered
something.
>> Male #3: Thanks for coming, I love your
work.
I have a mimeograph machine, I am terrible
at using it.
But I have a series of realizations like,
oh it matters what ink you use, oh it matters
what paper you use, but I missed the beginning
of your talk.
I was curious about how far down the rabbit
hole do you go with the particular paper?
I know people who, like, they are not happy
with what's available so they try to make
their own.
I was just curious like do you enjoy that
part of it and how far do you go to get it
just to your specifications?
>> Patricia: That's a good question.
Very, very far down the rabbit hole.
[audience laughs lightly] Another tremendous
pleasure in printing and I thinks it's one
of the things that really hooks people, especially
letter press printers, is paper.
A paper is just beautiful, beautiful stuff,
quality papers.
And they all print differently, they all feel
different, they have slightly different textures
and colors.
So you have to make adjustments for all of
that and you know when I would be conceiving
of a menu, making a plan, part of that is
what paper, what color is the paper, what's
it's going to do in the press.
And because not all papers are suitable for
block printing or letter press printing, that
kind of limits certain things.
But fortunately most fine papers are really,
really good.
I don't make paper, but you know we have done
all kinds of things like print an image and
then make a fan out of it.
Cut it and glue it to sticks in order to get
a printed fan, and then you just, there are
all kinds of things possible.
You build up your knowledge of materials and
inks and mixing colors and what happens when
you put one color on top of another and what
are you likely to get and all of that.
It's a cycle, it's trial and error, basically
no rules, you just keep, you do it until you
get what you want.
Yeah, yeah, but that's the fun of it.
That's what I was saying, that discovery is,
um, you start in one place and you just keep
adding to that and you get into all kinds
of new places.
[pause] Anyone else?
Thank you, thank you very much.
>> Male Announcer: Ok, can we get one more
round of applause for Patricia.